Brothers and sisters, just imagine for a
second that you give 10 pounds in
donation and that 10 pounds is used to
buy food or bricks or whatever to help
the people in Gaza. But then just
imagine this amazing deed that you want
to do, but we turn it into a
money-making machine. How?
The waqf is exactly that. They take your
money and the money that we are going to
put in in this waqf, this building, and
every single time the money generated
from that waqf, that building, is going
to go to our Palestinian brothers and
sisters for the next 20, 30, 40, 50, 60,
100, 150 years. And this will be a form
of true sadaqah jariyah. I myself will
be donating for that, inshallah. Click
the link below and donate. May Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala bless and preserve
you guys. As-salamu alaykum wa
rahmatullahi wa barakatuh, brothers and
sisters and dear friends. This is going
to be so funny. I mean, you imagine
using an argument and the same argument
backfires on you. This Zionist dirtbag,
this scum Adam, as you can see, this
genocidal
uh um
individual who is pro-genocide, who is
defending Israel at all costs, who
doesn't care about America, sends
American soldiers, ignores the griping
happening of those American girls so the
highest echelons can be used to
blackmail by Mossad. Nope, nothing said.
Nothing said, nada. Let's watch how Adam
well, not just Adam, uh sorry, Dave, not
just Dave and Piers Morgan absolutely
annihilate and bury him. Just wait for
the last bit, guys. It is epic how his
argument backfires on him. If Dave gets
out there and he tries to bully people
and say that he's so smart, he reads a
lot a lot of books. Good for you, Dave.
But what happens when you read it to
somebody run into somebody who's way
smarter and bullies the bully? I
remember uh growing up in this town of
Miami, so there was this kid who used to
pick on all the kids that that we were
at school with. And one day some new kid
showed up and he goes, "Oh, yeah, yeah,
yeah. Let's go, buddy. Let's do this."
And the bully goes, "Well, what do you
mean? What do you want to do?" And he
goes, "Oh, yeah, you want to fight
everybody. You want to take everybody
Okay, it seems like Adam's onto
something. He's going to make a
fantastic point. Just just just
Let's see what he Let's see Let's see
what he's got for us. for his lunch.
Let's go." And the new kid beat the crap
out of the bully. And here's what
happened with Dave. He's out there just
doing his little podcast thing, debating
on you said Ben Shapiro, 19-year-olds.
And Okay, good. Fantastic. The new kid
beat the crap out of the bully. Perfect.
Get to the point. What's the point,
Adam? Come on. You got something good
here. Let's go. Our Zionist friend.
Let's go. Then all of a sudden, this
whole conversation about Wesley Clark.
And I saw him on your podcast about a
week ago, Pierce. And this memo, here
you go, Dave. Remember this memo from
Wesley Clark that you used to cite
everything? That you used to cite Okay,
hold on a second. So, he's brought
something from a previous debate that
Dave Smith had. Okay. And Okay, all
right. He's got the whole props,
everything. Okay. Your point. Your
point, Adam. Let's go. Yeah.
That is adorable. Because your whole
foundation is based on some memo. Well,
I'm sorry. I'm not I'm not quite sure
what you're Adam, I'm not quite sure
what is the point you're making. The
point is Well, what the hell was the
point he was making?
You're in a debate. Imagine me going to
debate and go, "Yo, you know in another
debate, yeah, you got smashed. You were
having a debate. No, no, no, but in
another debate, you got smashed. Okay,
but we're having a debate together."
Brother, that's your subjective opinion.
Let's carry on. What am I wrong? This is
what happens. When it comes to Zionists,
you want to be a little bit Come on and
say Iran is the biggest state I've made
this point a million times on your show,
Pierce. I've seen when people come on
and say Iran is the biggest state
sponsor of terrorism, well, give me an
objective definition of what terrorism
means. And then let's apply that
standard universally.
>> Bang on point. What is the definition of
terrorism? Terrorism definition is to
use violence, acts of violence to for
political gains, okay, on innocent
people. That's what it is. And let's use
it universally. Let's be consistent.
Dave Smith is right. He's a Jew. He is a
Jew himself and he's damn right. That's
what I say, guys. Don't conflate the
Zionist with the Jew. Dave Smith is a
fine example of a Jewish person. And if
you're going to sit here and say, "Look,
America has given billions, tens of
billions of dollars to the IDF in the
last few years." We've also, by the way,
given a lot of weapons and money. Here,
your first guest on this show there, the
head of the Obama deep state, was using
Al-Qaeda bin Ladenite head choppers on
the ground in Libya and in Syria. And
yes, Adam, I would also consider it when
our politicians lie us into wars that
slaughter millions of innocent people
and in many cases target those innocent
people. I consider that terrorism as
well.
>> Bang on point. The man is consistent.
He's consistent. There's the answer,
Adam. And if you want to keep doing
this, buddy, you can tell me to check
the scoreboard. I'll run circles around
you on this, dude. Check the scoreboard.
>> Most of Bro, David is coming with facts,
bro. This guy will receive receipts.
He's got receipts. What's the other guy
doing? Yeah, there was a bully who done
uh bullied another guy in school and he
came and said, "Hey, I'm going to fight
you. You bullied here some papers."
Okay, what's your point? unpopular war
in American history going in. Check the
scoreboard. 13 dead Americans and 150
plus other wounded. Thousands of
innocents including little school girls
in Iran killed. It it dead innocent
Israelis. Hundreds of dead innocent
people in in Lebanon. Millions of
innocent people being displaced all at
the cost of tens of billions of dollars
and destroying Trump's coalition. Check
your scoreboard, Adam. Well, well, there
you go. That's what you call facts and
academia. That's what you're talking
about. Not some guy bullied me and I
bullied him back. And and your response?
Yeah, and what and and
Listen. And and and and and your
response?
I do respect the fact that Dave does
show up. He does. I mean, that's like,
okay, cool. You showed up. Respect to
that. I I will give Dave credit. But
Dave, And and the Could you imagine?
Nothing to said. I want to say my
opinion. I've got to give it to him. He
showed up. Okay, is that a reply for
that? This is why I'm going to keep
going back to this. To pretend that it
was an even match, an even debate. He
put you in a body bag and you're out
here still still doubling down on all
your positions when he went methodically
and surgically
>> This is the This is the saddest I've
never been in a debate where someone
just fell back to someone else's debate.
Boom boom boom. What name one of the
booms. Make the point for yourself. Me
and you are supposed to be debating
here, brother.
>> from Wesley Clark. The the memo from But
it was a pretty unusual debating
strategy to spend 10 minutes of this
debate talking about another debate that
most viewers may not see. Okay, bro.
Even Piers Morgan, come on, bro. Even
this guy is speaking some sense. He
mostly speaks nonsense, yeah? What's
your point? Why are you talking about
another debate?
What's wrong with you?
Yes, it's pretty There's other debates
that we can bring up. The fact Dave Oh
my gosh. He does that TO MY BRO. STOP
talking about other people's debate. He
goes, "Nah, I got a counter." Okay, what
is that? He lost other people in the
debate. Bro, I thought you just told
you. Stop talking about other people's
debate. How are you now mentioning the
same dumb thing? What a stupid guy.
When's the last time you were in the
Middle East?
Okay, so this is what you're falling
back to now. Ah, good. Check this out
now, yeah. When have you been to the
Middle East? When have you been to
Israel? Okay. Okay. All right, is that a
point yet? That Douglas Murray has done
him, but still didn't work out cuz even
Joe Rogan called him out. But let's
let's carry on. What happens to him?
Right. No, you know the answer. You're
not asking.
I've asked you many times and you know
the I have not been to the Middle East.
Go do your best Douglas Murray acting
job. Adam Adam brother, I was You've
never been, yeah.
So You are humiliating yourself right
now. I don't care to be friends. You're
just humiliating yourself right now.
You've been humiliating yourself for the
past 2 years. Basically saying that
America's a terrorist organization. That
the IDF is a terrorist organization. And
you're whitewashing actual terrorists.
Do you see what's going on in in the
West? Do you see what's going on where
Piers Morgan lives in London? Do you see
what's going on all over the world? Why
are you making stuff up
cuz you have nothing?
You're just making stuff up cuz you have
nothing.
Well, they are they are terrorists. They
are terrorists. What do you mean? What
are you trying to say? Like making us
sound like Piers Morgan. Just cuz they
are our allies in the West and that what
that means that that is they can justify
for genocide? The way you're talking
about. Of course there is acts of
terrorism that they've done. Are you are
you stupid? Let's go. This is where it
backfires on him. Watch how it backfires
on him. Piers Morgan well, so
uh
demolishes him.
Piers Morgan lives in London. Do you see
what's going on all over the world?
Why are you making stuff up cuz you have
nothing?
You're just making stuff up cuz you have
nothing, dude.
You just said that reality is a
terrorist organization. If you brought
my country into He's anti-American and
here I am as a proud American saying
that he doesn't know what he's talking
about. You said that you said that they
couldn't talk about the Middle East cuz
he hasn't been there much. When was the
last time you were in England? OOH,
KNOCK OUT BROTHER. You're nervous. Sleep
tight. Salam alaikum. Alaikum as-salam.
As-salamu alayda.
Brother,
when was the last time you was in the
UK? You You see how the Zionist
shifts it because this is their
um escapegoat. That seems where they're
using this. Oh, Sharia grooming gangs
have got nothing else. They know it's a
bull crap. It's just all a big fat bull
crap lie in the sense where not that
that grooming has happened. That's
That's happened. The grooming gangs etc.
And a lot majority of what uh grooming
gangs are white people by the way. Okay,
and Peter white middle-aged men. That's
not the issue we are. The issue is look
how they are digressing and going to
Sharia. Okay, when was the last time you
were in the UK, my friend?
Owned.
LOOK AT LOOK AT LOOK AT LOOK AT THIS
DRINK. WHAT IS THAT? OWNED. OH, DAMN. I
just got owned. Oh, damn. I just said
the same thing to Dave Smith and I've
never been in the UK. Let me drink some
water. Oh.
I spent many much time in England. My
ex-wife was
>> When was the When was the last time? She
wasn't a sheep shagger. When was the
last time? What the hell's
What's What What the hell These Zionists
are so stupid. She wasn't a sheep
shagger.
Is that Is that supposed to be some
academia academic response? My I My My
ex-wife, yes, she wasn't
What's your point?
The last time
The last time I was in the in Europe in
England
>> Oh, look how he is rattled. He's shaking
his head. You know when you get a right
or a left hook in sparring and you're
like, "Oh, damn. Where am I today? What
time is it? What did I eat for
breakfast?" That's how he is, bro. He's
finished.
The Middle East, where would you like me
to go?
>> No, England. England.
The Wow, the silence.
Oh God, this is so satisfying.
Are you guys enjoying this as much as I
am? The last time I was in England was
about 8 years ago.
>> Right. So, this idea, let me tell you
Let me tell you the last time I was in
Israel This idea that
There is a There is a weird idea that
there is
There is a weird idea
There are many people on Are you SAYING
THAT IT'S NOT GOING to a country? Adam,
many people on the Hang on. Many people
on the conservative right in America sit
under the illusion that my country has
been taken over by radical Muslims. Let
me tell you, I have lived here on and
off for the last 8 years, unlike you,
and respectfully, we have not been taken
over by radical Muslims. It just hasn't
happened the way it's It's sold by
people like Tommy Robinson to Americans.
And you're all laughing at How would you
How would you define it then, Piers? How
would you define it then, Piers? I think
we have a Muslim Good. Okay, fair
question. Okay, let's go. Okay, let's
see. What's someone that lives in the
UK? population which is predominantly
peaceful and inclusive and has settled
well and we have some radical members of
of
radical Muslims as we have radical
members of other religions. Exactly.
Like, you know, as Muslims we don't have
our own ambulances like the Jewish
community, have our own police officers
like the Jewish community have our own
segments in hospitals where it's only
for the Jewish people.
We don't have that. Yep, we integrate
very well. Don't worry. And we have to
be very wary about it.
>> What are the What are the members of
radical What are the What are the
members of radical religions? And we
have had And we have had severe
immigration control issues run by
successive Conservative and Labour
governments who frankly lost control of
our border both to illegal immigration
but also allowed way too many people in
legally. And these are proper legitimate
things to be discussed. But framing it,
as some people like to do, as my
country's been overrun and overtaken by
radical Muslims, is just a lie. It's
just not true. So, yes, there are things
to be concerned about and yes, I want to
see I want to see everyone who comes
here assimilate and everyone who lives
here assimilate into our culture. Of
course, I do. But this idea that we've
been overrun and overtaken is nonsense.
Yeah. Owned. Owned. There is no Sharia
law being operated legally in this
country. End. Thank you, Piers. Thank
you for enlightening me. So, you're
saying it's all overblown that Islamic
of of of of of of of of of of of of of
of of of of of
And let me take you on a guided tour of
the UK and trust me, you'll be fine.
I'm sure you're going to one of the most
dangerous places, Piers.
I'm sure you're not going to Birmingham
or Brick Lane or anything like that.
>> Brick Lane, best curries in England. I
love Birmingham, fantastic place.
>> Incredible incredible Bangladeshi curry.
I'll take you I'll take you there.
He got owned. He got absolutely
annihilated, guys. Hope you enjoyed this
as much as I did. And you can see how
desperate they are. Adam, you and
Patrick Pet flipping Pet the Chihuahua,
David, will believe in that and your
little numpty stupid audience will
believe that O Sharia taking over the
UK.
People who live here know that it's not
taken over. So, it's all bull crap.
Brothers and sisters, that's what I have
to say. Inshallah, may Allah Subhana Wa
Ta'ala continue exposing these people.
Share this video far and wide. Let
people see the reality because let me
tell you something.
October the 7th, what happened there?
Okay, and again, we condemn the killing
of any group targeting innocent people.
That there showed the reality of what
the true reality of Israel. And this's
going to be the end. It's the beginning
of the end when they showed what they
are capable of and what they've been
doing and the ties that they have to the
people of Islands and what they're doing
with Americans. They control America.
As-salamu alaykum wa rahmatullahi wa
barakatuh.